artists antennas the Skylark is also
known as Christie's Tosca lackeys I'm a
professor of computer science at MIT and
the Department of Electrical Engineering
and computer science and in computer
science and AI the laboratory
I love my work for it focuses on de
terror face you think of your science
and I get game theory and economics and
there are several reasons so I'm
interested in this interface one is a
very practical reason and that's that a
lot of human economic activity is
happening online on computation of
platforms so you need some handle to
design these platforms in a way that
takes into account besides the
computational issues also the strategic
an incentive issues so that's a very
fact of reason why this interface is
important especially when you know a lot
of the economic activities up in your
line but there's also a deeper
philosophical reason why this is
important and that relates to the
foundations of game theory in economics
which have to do with bounded
rationality when you make predictions
about what humans in a strategic
scenario are going to be doing you
should also take into account that
humans and are not infinitely rational
and in particular they have a
computational constraints in what
they're able to think about in a finite
amount of time so you really have to
inject into your game theoretic and
economic approach to analyzing behavior
also the computational barriers that
humans are going to be facing when
they're making decisions so that's yet
another reason why this interface is
very interesting lastly there are very
interesting mathematics and very
interesting computational questions that
arise once you start thinking about our
interaction that motivates that it
offends
[Music]
Nash equilibrium is a mathematical
theory whose goal is to characterize
what happens in now when strategic
individuals interact in a game or in a
very general notion of what a game is
which is basically a strategic
interaction roughly speaking a Nash
equilibrium is a strategy for every
individual participating in that
interaction with with the probability
that given what the other players but
the other individuals are doing a
non-player unilaterally you can improve
his position by updating a strategy so
that's a natural people it's a choice of
strategy for every participant so that
everybody is happy at least they can all
in the sense that they cannot even
lather and improve their situation by
changing their strategy it could be that
you know where some global mood can make
everybody happy but every individual
move cannot
so what my work with the Goldberg and
probably tree house sold is that when
game is very complex when a strategic
situation becomes very complex it has a
lot of moving parts
I love notes for the players to attune
to update their strategies then it may
be computationally really hard for the
players to actually arrive at Nash
equilibria which philosophically implies
that if agents are computationally
bounded which they are they will
actually not be able to discover a Nash
equilibria in particular in this case
the predictions of Nash equilibria
should not be trusted as you know
characterizing what really happens in
the situation of conflict